[Applaus]
ist natürlich auch eine Größe nasser war
das unangefochtene Oberhaupt dieser
Familie Arafat ist nachgekommen
sie sind auch bekannt dafür dass sie
schwere Raubtaten begangen haben
Gerüchten zufolge wird es in Berlin
wahrscheinlich kaum ein wohnungsbordell
geben was nicht sozusagen Schutzgeld an
die Familie bezahlt unser Rechtssystem
wird nicht anerkannt entweder gibt's auf
die Fresse oder es wird mit Geld
geregelt man hat Netzwerke geschaffen in
die Politik in Behörden in Richtung
Medien also ich bin schon eher der
Macher bushido hat natürlich eine
Hauptrolle gespielt das war ja eine der
Haupteinnahmequellen
man ist über die roten Teppiche gelaufen
man hat schon gewissen Status erreicht
den man sonst natürlich nie erreicht
hätte und dadurch sind sie auch mit
ihrer relativ kleinen Personenzahl doch
so mächtig geworden
[Musik]
Berlin 5 mai 2022 an diesem sonnigen
Frühlingstag erweisen 1000 Trauergäste
einer klaren Größe die letzte Ehre
der Verstorbene Mohammed Rabi 25 Jahre
alt hobbyboxer der staatenlose
Palästinenser vorbestraft wegen
gefährlicher Körperverletzung Betrug und
Diebstahl wurde am 30 April dieses
Jahres
Opfer einer brutalen Messerattacke
hier ein Video des Schwerverletzten Rabi
gefilmt von einem Bekannten bei einem
Volksfest war es zwischen Mohammed und
mehreren Männern zu einem Streit
gekommen ein Angreifer sticht mehrfach
auf ihn ein wenig später verstirbt der
hobbyboxer im Krankenhaus die Täter
können flüchten der vorläufige Höhepunkt
eines jahrelang tobenden clankrieges
denn auch Mohammeds älterer Bruder Nidal
wurde ermordet bei einem Familienausflug
auf dem Tempelhofer Feld 2018 wird er
von einem rivalisierenden Clan Mitglied
erschossen
hier Bilder von seiner Beerdigung
es ist derselbe Friedhof auf dem
Mohammed begraben wurde
[Musik]
Berlin ist seit Jahren Schauplatz
blutiger Auseinandersetzungen zwischen
verfeindeten Clans es geht um Schutzgeld
Raub Erpressung Prostitution und
Drogenhandel es geht um Macht und um
Millionen im Visier der Fahnder die Abu
chakas eine der einflussreichsten
Großfamilien in Berlin
sind eben sehr gut vernetzt in die
Politik in Behörden in Richtung Medien
in die Immobilienbranche man hat
Netzwerke geschaffen die andere Familien
überhaupt nicht haben und dadurch sind
sie auch mit ihrer relativ kleinen
Personenanzahl doch so mächtig geworden
das operative Zentrum der Großfamilie
liegt im Berliner Stadtteil Neukölln
bei Ruth wird das Viertel um die
Sonnenallee genannt
ein Großteil der Geschäfte Imbissbuden
Handyläden
Shisha-Cafés befindet sich in
libanesischer Hand
der Bezirk gilt bei den Behörden als
sozialer Brennpunkt
allein im Jahr 2021 registrierte die
Polizei hier mehr als 40.000 Straftaten
die meisten davon im Bereich Diebstahl
Drogendelikte und Körperverletzungen
[Musik]
wir treffen den Kommunalpolitiker Falko
CDU seit 12 Jahren ist der in Neukölln
Stadtrat es gibt wenige die den Bezirk
so gut kennen wie er auffallend die
immer größer werdenden Clanstrukturen
ist natürlich in Neukölln auch eine
Größe die machen das aber etwas klüger
als vielleicht andere Familien die
versuchen das eher so unterm Radar ihre
kriminellen Geschäfte auch zu machen
deshalb treten sie gar nicht so große in
Erscheinung mit Straftaten ist auch
immer wieder schwierig für die
Strafverfolgungsbehörden danach zuweisen
sie haben aber hier eine auftreten und
auch einen Namen
[Musik]
das haben sie vor allem ihrer
jahrelangen Beziehung zu dem bekannten
Rapper Bushido zu verdanken der Sohn
eines Tunesiers und einer deutschen mit
dem bürgerlichen Namen Anis Mohammed
Josef Ferchichi Beteiligte die Abu
chakas an seine musik-person ist er
hielt dafür den Schutz der Familie
in den Kriminellen klaren Strukturen ein
übliches Geschäftsmodell
2017 trennte sich Bushido von den
abuchakas nachdem er heftigen
Bedrohungen ausgesetzt war
seit August 2020 führt der Rapper einen
Prozess gegen Clanchef Arafat und drei
seiner Brüder es geht um gefährliche
Körperverletzung schwere räuberische
Erpressung
jahrelang standen die abou-chakers auf
Promi-Parties rap-konzerten und roten
Teppich in ebenso im Rampenlicht wie er
einstiger Goldjunge Bushido
dabei begann die Geschichte der
abou-chakas ganz und gar nicht glamourös
der islam-wissenschaftler ralf garbahn
hat den Ursprung der Großfamilie
erforscht die Abu Schalke gehören zu der
Kategorie der Bauern aus nordpolistina
die haben das Land bestellt haben von
der Landwirtschaft gelebt und wurden
vertrieben und kamen in den Libanon
dort leben sie in einem Flüchtlingscamp
nahe der Stadt bahlbeck die Gegend
gehört zu den ärmsten im Libanon und ist
Hochburg der Terrororganisation
in diesem Flüchtlingslager weil die
Arbeitsmöglichkeiten gering waren die
könnten nur
Saisonarbeit betreiben also wenn die
Ämter kam haben sie ein paar Monate
gearbeitet aber sonst nicht und das
Lager war im Vergleich zu anderen
ziemlich
arm als 1975 im Libanon der Bürgerkrieg
ausbricht entscheidet sich das Ehepaar
said und nasimirten
ihr Ziel die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
West Berlin die Eltern von Carmen mit
zwei Söhne jetzt haben sie sechs schöner
Damen in Berlin weitere Vierer erzeugt
und die Kinder versuchen mit alle Kraft
so viele Kinder zu kriegen wie sie
können weil die Stärke eines Clans mit
der Zahl von den Jungs in der Familie
gezählt werden
die beiden ältesten Brüder der
abou-chakers nasser und Ali kommen im
Libanon zur Welt Rommel Arafat Mohammed
und jassa in Deutschland zudem haben die
sechs Brüder noch drei Schwestern die
aber kaum in der Öffentlichkeit
auftreten immer mehr Familienmitglieder
folgen den abou-chakers in die
Bundesrepublik nach Schätzungen der
Polizei leben heute zwischen 200 und 300
Familienmitglieder in Berlin viele im
Stadtteil Neukölln
die Familie aber Chaka ist vor allen
Dingen dafür bekannt steht jedenfalls zu
vermuten dass es aus dem Drogenmilieu
entsprechende
Straftaten gibt sie sind auch bekannt
dafür dass sie schwere Raubtaten
begangen haben das prominenteste
Beispiel der Überfall des Pokerturniers
und das sind natürlich schon sehr sehr
nachdrückliche Straftaten die auch
Eindruck machen sollen übrigens in der
Community und dadurch steigt sozusagen
das Ansehen der Respekt und der macht
einen Fluss und das eben genau das
gefährliche wo ich sage da muss der
Staat definitiv intervenieren
[Musik]
die Auseinandersetzungen zwischen
verfeindeten clan-mitgliedern werden
immer brutaler und nicht selten am
hellichten Tag auf offener Straße
ausgetragen
im Herbst 2021 eskaliert die Gewalt vor
der Neuköllner Bäckerei allen nabusi am
29 September attackieren 10 Personen
Clan Größe nasser Abou Chaka verletzen
ihn am Kopf
am 3 Oktober dann ein erneuter Überfall
vor der Baklava Bäckerei diese
Handyaufnahmen zeigen wie Angreifer mit
Macheten und Baseballschlägern den Laden
an der Karl-Marx-Straße stürmen sie
verletzen den Inhaber zerstören Mobiliar
auf ihrer Flucht versprühen sie den
Inhalt eines Feuerlöschers
solche Angriffe werden auf offener
Straße ausgetragen unser Rechtssystem
wird nicht anerkannt es wird über Gewalt
entweder gibt's auf die Fresse oder es
wird mit Geld geregelt manchmal kommt
noch ein Friedensrichter dazu der das
aushandelt aber deswegen egal ist ganz
klar wir sind Chef der Straße wir regeln
unsere Probleme auch auf der Straße und
alles andere ist uns egal und es ist
Thema ist auch das viele junge Leute
beeindruckt sind davon die sagen WOW der
wurde auf offener Straße angegangen wir
können das auch wir regeln unsere
Probleme untereinander so keine Polizei
kein Gericht keine Staatsanwaltschaft so
und ist ein ganz schlechtes Vorbild
deshalb muss der ich hatte auch klare
Sprache sprechen doch entschlossene
Kampfansagen gegen die clankriminalität
stoßen nicht überall in Berlin auf
Zuspruch
hier eine Aufruf gegen die
schwerpunkteinsätze
offensichtlich kommen die nicht bei
jedem gut an
seit 2019 führen Polizei und Behörden
vor allem in Berlin und
Nordrhein-Westfalen verstärkte Razzien
in Wettbüros und Shisha-Bars durch der
Unmut über diese Null toleranz-strategie
ist der Milieu groß sogar so groß dass
Politiker wie Falco Lieke persönlich
bedroht werden
[__] ist so eine gängige
Beleidigung du Hund oder liegehund
hatten wir alles schon es gab aber auch
schon mal Zusammenkünfte wohl noch eine
nähere Diskussion entstanden ist wo dann
auch ganz klar
angesagt wurde was auf deine Kinder auf
oder in Neukölln gibt es immer mal ein
Mord
es kommt auch Lob aus der Bevölkerung
danke schön alles Gute auch für Sie
tschüss ich sag mal aus solchen
Hinweisen oder Kommentaren ziehe ich
meine Motivation das sind dann mitunter
auch manchmal ganz kleine Sachen wenn
sich jemand bedankt hat per E-Mail weil
irgendwas geklappt hat wofür ich mich
eingesetzt habe das ist für mich
sozusagen der Sprit um auch weiter zu
machen und auch zu kämpfen hier in
Neukölln was zu verändern und das ist
genau mein Punkt
[Musik]
Berlin ist Hochburg der Clan
Kriminalität
2021 gingen hier nachweislich
849 Straftaten auf das Konto von
polizeibekannten Großfamilien bei der
Personenkontrolle im albustan treffen
die Ermittler am 21 Juli 2007 auch auf
Rap-Star Bushido der Rap-Star eröffnet
der Großfamilie den ersehnten
gesellschaftlichen Aufstieg die
abou-chakers beherrschen die Straße und
das musikbus
[Musik]